one of the big difficulties students
have in a problem that involves many
objects is to successfully identify
third law interaction pairs so today I'd
like to look at a problem which shows us
how to think about that so what we're
gonna look at is third law interaction
pairs
now the problem I'd like to consider is
the following suppose we have a block
one and another block two sitting on
block one on a surface and our surface
has friction and I'd like to it push
block one with a force F and now I'd
like to use Newton's second law to
determine what is the maximum force I
can push that block to will not slip so
I'm trying to find F max such that block
two does not slip now how do we even
begin to think about this well the first
thing that we have to decide is when we
apply Newton's second law
our first question will be what is the
system
that we'll choose and in this problem
there are three separate ways to think
about this just to show you example so
system a will be block one system B will
be blocked two and system C will be
blocks one and block two and given these
different systems I can get different I
can address different questions and
we'll see that as we develop this so
let's start with block one and let's
look at we'll start with breaking our
problem down into blocks one and block
two and let's draw the Freebody diagrams
on those blocks trying to identify
action-reaction pairs so let's begin
with block one first off we know there's
gravitational force and the earth is the
other pair there which we're not drawing
there is friction between the surfaces
so there's a friction between the ground
and block one there is the normal force
of the ground on block 1 block 2 is
sitting on block 1 so there's a normal
force of block 2 on block 1 and finally
as you push block 1 there's a friction
force between bak 2 and block one that's
opposing the fact that block 1 is being
pushed forward so we have a friction
force here between blocks 2 & 1 now this
friction down here is kinetic but if the
blocks are moving together this friction
here is static so those are the free
body force diagrams on one
I'll choose unit vectors in a moment now
what about two so let's draw two well
again m2 G the earth is the other
element of the interaction pair and now
block one is pushing block two up
so we have block one pushing block two
up and notice our indices make it very
easy to see that our first Newton's
third law interaction pair is the normal
force of contact between the two blocks
now what else here's the subtle thing is
that this whole system will move to the
right what's the force that's making
block to move to the right
well it's static friction so static
friction from block one on block 2 this
is the static friction is pausing block
2 to move to the right and now we can
see again our our third law interaction
pair so in this problem we have two
third law pairs this one and I won't
connect the line there and those are the
third law pairs now we can call these we
know by the third law that they're equal
opposite in magnitude we can identify F
we can call this one and if we want just
to save ourselves the problem of writing
a lot of indices once we've done that
we're now ready to apply Newton's second
law we haven't yet figured out what the
condition is that it will just slip
we'll get to that but for the moment we
can now apply vector decomposition so we
need to choose some unit vectors because
I'm pushing the system this way it makes
sense for me to choose my I hat to the
right so here I'm going to choose I have
1 and J hat one
now over here I could choose the same
unit vectors even though I'm thinking
about this as a completely separate
problem with its own coordinate system
and I'll choose I had 2 and J hat 2 but
because these unit vectors are in the
same direction they're equal and they're
both moving in the positive eye
directions and so the excel I expect
both a 1 and a 2 to be
positive and now I can write down on
block 1 I can write down f1 equals m1 a1
and because we have two different
directions I'll separate out I like to
call this my scorecard and now I look at
the forces oh I missed the pushing force
but that's an interesting exercise when
you I looked at this diagram I saw I had
two forces going this way I had no force
acting that way I went back I checked my
Freebody diagram and recognize that I
forgot to put F in there always a good
exercise to double-check your Freebody
diagrams before you apply Newton's laws
so now in the x-direction we have the
pushing force minus the static friction
- we'll call this F K minus the kinetic
friction and that's equal to m1 a1 now
in the vertical direction we have the
ground friction and ground 1 - block -
pushing down on block 1 - the
gravitational force and there is no
acceleration in that direction and I
double-check my Freebody diagrams I
check my signs and that looks right to
me now for block 2
I'll apply the same analysis F 2 equals
m2 a to separate out my two unit
directions notice even though these unit
vectors are the same I'm emphasizing
that I'm talking about block 2 I could
have chosen different coordinate systems
if I want now I look at my Freebody
diagrams on block 2 I see that it's
static friction is the only one in the
positive on how direction so I have F
equals m2 a2 and in the vertical
directions I have that my force between
the blocks
the normal force between the blocks -
gravity is zero